would you smash Margot Robbie if she was
your cousin
I mean that's easier for Allen because
we would just she'd be adopted but like
no no no no first cousin first cousin
first Blood cousin together back in the
day that was normal
huh that was normal back in the day
Cousin [__] is just normal I agree
with you now Rami has a great joke about
that actually he does yeah but I'm
curious about this with Margot Robbie
because far back in the day when it was
this normal 90s
about a time when I was born I think
I'm curious because Margot Robbie is
someone's cousin
and they have to act like they they have
to do the whole thing my cousin dude
I've noticed since I was kid you know
what I mean like oh Margo or whatever
her name is you know what is there a
stupid accent no no no
no
no dogs no you don't even put the dogs
in my mouth crazy we Maggie
whatever [__] what is it what is it
you're making her Scottish I don't know
why oh yes I don't know how to do
Australia all right yeah I can't do that
that's me cousin
anyway so that person has to act like he
wouldn't smash but he would yeah yeah
yeah but we wouldn't [__] our cousins no
no
it's because they're ugly that's the
thing that that's the thing
my cousins
that's the thing that we have to
acknowledge is there's a hotness level
yeah they're not ugly but there's a
hotness where it's like yo yo you called
Gandhi 11 year old [__] you can't just
say your cousin says dog [__]
because it's a Rotten Tomato
[Laughter]
there you go dude is hot yeah so
yeah gay incest ain't even that bad
you can't reproduce no yeah there's no
cost that's a great Point facts okay
I don't think gayen says should be
illegal illegal
male or female yeah and then girls you
can understand why people think it
should be illegal though right because
they're cousin yeah we just we just made
gay legal like 2006. yeah you can't yeah
I agree with you on that one
but I do think
we just we just don't have
beautiful enough cousins where it makes
sense
which hurts your heart to say but you
all have said it this is so weird that's
true you either go my cousins are fine
right you either say yo my cousins are
hot yeah or and I would you know what I
mean but even if they're hot they're not
Margot Robbie
but what I'm saying is there's a level
we acknowledged before there's a level
where we would Smash and then we go
would we smash our cousins so we're
saying we don't have super hot cousins
that's what we all saying right now
right sorry sorry Schultz's do you know
what I mean but no can we talk about
like third and fourth cousins now now
Alex
that's
you think I'm gonna let my my my dad's
sister's cousin getting away with his
[__]
come on where's the second cousin I
don't even know but all I know is that
at my grandmother's funeral
this was a good what maybe 10 15 years
ago that was just one that came talk
that [__] none of us have ever met her
talk somehow she was related to us [__]
all the cousins was like yo who is
thirsty
I'm talking about yo we can open drinks
it was that bad what's wrong with that
just pray she's like it looks like her
mom and
who got the same taste
that's just doing Mad uncle's away yeah
she was second or third yeah yeah
that's a stranger I found some data by
the way okay children of first cousin
unions have an increased risk of genetic
disorders do you wanna know what
percentage
two to three percent
in some parts of the world 20 to 60 of
all marriages between close biological
relatives
whoa that's a little weird that's most
of human existence bro hey
gene pool is shallow yeah
yeah yeah
that's what it is dog we're smart maybe
that's why two percent is it worth it
Margot two percent yeah yeah
if she was your sister